as the confirmation vote for kavanaugh
looks
set for this weekend we can't forget
what happened at the very
start of this whole fight most
importantly how did reporters
get their hands on christine ford's
account in the first place now the
washington post says that
ford made the initial contact through
the anonymous
tip line it only after she had built a
rapport with the post reporter emma
brown
did ford decide to come forward and give
her
on the record account but i want to play
this moment during the hearing which
really jumped out at me when i first
watched it
that i don't think is getting enough
attention ford was
asked about the decision to come forward
and said this
ultimately because reporters were
sitting outside of my home
a reporter appeared in my graduate
classroom and i mistook her for a
student
and she came up to ask me a question and
i
thought that she was a student and it
turned out that she was a reporter
the washington post in a statement to
the ingram angle tonight
reaffirmed that ford came to them
solely through their tip line and that
it was reporters from other outlets who
confronted ford at her home
and place of residence so where does
that leave
us back to democratic members of the
senate judiciary committee
now remember senator feinstein was
confronted about possible leaks last
week
and had this kind of interesting
exchange with senator john
cornyn can you tell us that your staff
did not leak it
oh i don't believe my staff would leak
it i have not
asked that question directly but i do
not believe you know that
have you asked your staff or other staff
members in the judiciary committee
pardon me well jennifer reminds me i've
asked her before about it
well that's true
well the jennifer she referenced there
is a woman named jennifer
duck her longtime chief of staff who now
works on the judiciary committee for the
democrats
and seems to be the authority on the
question of leaks
we take the post at their word that
their involvement in this story came
solely through the tip line
but what we're less clear on uh tonight
is
how the other reporters found themselves
in possession of ford's identity it's
just strange
we reached out to feinstein's office for
clarity and
as of five minutes ago they had not
gotten back to us
here to react howie kurtz host of media
buzz right here on fox news
and american conservative union head
matt schlapp all right howie let's start
with you
assuming the post is being honest here
how do we think all these other
reporters
found out about ford and her account
extremely strong circumstantial evidence
that it came from feinstein's staff
because staff members don't tell the
boss
hey i'm about to leak this and look
where the leaks went first it was the
left-wing site the intercept they found
out about the anonymous letter then the
new york times said oh it's about a
woman and
some sort of sexual thing and then it
was a buzzfeed reporter
uh also a liberal site that went to
ford's home and ford's uh
where she was teaching and then finally
the new yorker gets the actual letter
and publishes it it was at that point
that christine ford said people know who
i am journalists know who i am i'm going
to
tell my own story to the washington post
but matt the idea that
some person like christine ford just
okay what how can i get this
i'll just type it on the anonymous tip
line
i don't know it's my spidey senses
something about this story just
doesn't add up and given the the
importance of
guarding these documents uncorroborated
allegations of the senate judiciary
committee to avoid this happening
again shouldn't it be the case that the
cell phones emails texts
whether deleted or not are preserved you
can get them back any
text you delete sorry you can get it
back all those are preserved and we find
out
any connections between feinstein's
office right and the washington post
specifically
friendships romantic relationships
between feinstein's people
or friendships and the post yeah so out
of thomas and anita hill
there was a certain some learnings and
one of them is
when you go back and do this fbi report
only senators can look at it
i think we're going to need some
learnings out of this laura here's the
here's what we know
either dr ford is a terrible victim in
all this because she didn't want to stay
confidential
or dr ford in combination with these
democrat staffers and members and maybe
anna eshoo the democrat that started
this whole thing
and maybe with the lawyers who they
found for her they were trying
aggressively
to push dr ford to be public so they
were actually leaking
on dr ford to get her out there because
they wanted
the emotions of that hearing that's what
they wanted they thought that would
derail it all
right they got the opposite yeah howie
the um the washington post
responded to us today by saying no one
leaked anything to us she ultimately
decided she was willing to put her name
on the record after reporters from other
outlets
appeared at her home and workplace at
which time we chose to publish
her story again does that ring
true it is true that the washington post
didn't go with the story without it
on the record interviews and saw the
therapist notes and all that and tried
to do
uh a legitimate investigation but i've
covered so many of these stories laura
what happens is
that becomes like an open secret a
source tells one reporter maybe a source
tells two reporters reporters talk to
each other
nobody quite wants to go with it because
it's an explosive allegation they don't
have the complainant on the record
but eventually gets out there and
somebody goes and tries to
ambush the person or hang out or stalk
them
and that's how it eventually hits print
and and and i i believe
that christine ford was sort of
pressured into going pop quick she
clearly did not want to do okay there's
another exchange we have to focus on
this was also regarding the
um was it the triangle what is it called
the the double triangle thank you
this was chris cuomo and don lemon last
night let's watch
how does he sign it uh he signs it ffff
boy he sure loves fun of that stuttering
guy
uh that's not stuttering that's what he
says it was that is not stuttering again
do a google search that ffff is
not stuttering okay and
devil's triangle is not a drinking game
all right he knows that everybody else
does except for maybe some senators who
want to believe him
other tweets this is really fascinating
tv
other tweets if if judge kavanaugh is
shown to have lied to the committee
about devil
it's jeff's like it's over jeff flank oh
yes oh it turns out of course it was a
drinking game
and other friends of kavanagh gets in
sworn
statements to the fbi it looks like in
this report like yeah this is a drinking
game
guys apparently you're a bunch of geeks
and never played it you got to give don
lemon a lot of credit he seems to know a
lot about this uh
he accused me the other day on a show of
being a racist because i i've been
criticizing kamala harris
and cory booker for their outrageous
behavior it's like what passes for
news no it's racism and uh but it's okay
to pick out a catholic that's one thing
that we've learned in this whole process
and i just think that
why don't we just cover the fact i'd
love to know his jurisprudence what's
his philosophy
drinking games devil's trying to say
that that malaysian jet went down in a
black hole
some months ago that could be racist too
yeah no no it was like could it have
been a black hole or something but
i was more careful with my f's i'm not
going anywhere near that guys
uh fantastic segment we're going to stay
on the leak issue by the way